So to find out what happens when we run this
line of code, we will go back in time and
look at a video from a previous lesson when we
were drawing shapes. For now, you can think of a class
as a neatly packaged box that puts things together really
well. And it allows us to write code like turtle.turtle
with these strange-looking brackets as if we were calling a
function. In fact, when we do run this piece of code,
we are, in fact, calling a function, a function
called init, which is defined inside the class Turtle. Init
stands for initialize. And what it does is it
creates space in memory for a new instance or a
new object of the class Turtle. This instance, we
called Brad. Okay, so we are back to the present
time. Now, we started out by defining a file
called media.py. Let me place it up on the board.
Notice that I place this file outside the Python standard
library. Inside that file, we then defined a class called Movie.
After that, we wrote a line of code
that said media.movie. And what that did, was that
it called the init function Define inside class
Movie. And that created a new instance. That instance
we called Toy Story. So to summarize, this
function init initializes or creates space and memory for
the new instance Toy Story. By the way,
this new function init, is also called a constructor
because it constructs space and memory for the new
instance, which in this case happens to be Toy Story.
So thus far, we've encountered two new words that we
can add to our new word list. The first one
is instance, which in this case, happens to be Toy
Story. And the second one is a constructor, which in
this case, is the function init. Now, we will
revisit these words soon. But for now, let's define init.